the scenes were like inside the
courtroom there we are supporters
outside
poor thing
Mike you don't really need any
explanation for those pictures do you
well that's what 27 years of waiting
does to people I guess you know 27 years
as we were saying earlier Dermot you
know a generation has grown up a lot of
the family members have died in those 27
years they never got to see this day
they never got to see justice some
people who've been campaigning all of
those years and I think whatever you may
feel about this now watching these
pictures one thing that I can say for
sure having covered this for 27 years is
that the tenacity of those families has
been quite incredible they have never
given up despite the many many knock
backs they have had over the past 27
years they have fought and fought for
justice and now I think they can allow
themselves to believe that justice is
here as we were about to say not the end
of the story the focus now turns onto
any criminal investigations okay we've
got Nick Martin now my colleague our
colleague Nick Martin coming to join us
here because Sir Nick's been inside the
court feeding us an awful lot of that
information that we brought you as
quickly as we possibly could right here
on Sky News Nick but first of all well
you know forget all the decisions the
deliberations what about that set that
emotion we've seen some example of it
those of us that have been outside the
call what was it like inside well you
saw some of the emotions spill out of
the court just now Dermot but inside as
the coroner was reading out that 14
questionnaire to members of the jury it
was apparent that there was a huge
amount of relief being released into the
core especially when they got to that
crucial question question number six
which the jury said that they had
determined that the 96 who died that day
had been
unlawfully killed and as soon as that
happens the court just erupted into
shrieks and one person shouted thank you
thank you to the members of the jury and
what we're seeing now is this spilling
out here into the sunshine here in
Warrington where these inquests have
been going on now for two years and it
was incredibly emotional in the court as
the jury was being taken through all
those because they must mean I mean
there must been incredibly tense knit
because of course you know we we knew
they'd come to their conclusion
yesterday in the corner likely said well
we'll give it a give it a day so as
everyone who wants to be here can get
here but of course nobody knew which way
the decision had gone and you've been
talking to to the families they must
have had a nail-biting few hours well I
spoke to as we were sitting waiting for
the court to resume I spoke to some of
the relatives Margaret Aspinall who has
been at the forefront of campaigning and
she looked actually very relaxed and a
lot of them were chatting holding hands
hugging there didn't seem to be a huge
amount of tension this morning I think
for many of them it was the feeling that
at least they were going to get some
conclusion today and I think deep down
many of them had guessed perhaps what
the jury's responses would be so not a
huge amount of tension I choose quite
relaxed and so what happens now so the
the coroner said right we will take to
take a pause here I suspect in part two
to let this sink in to let some of the
emotion to seep out and then there's
still quite a lot to go through in these
inquests a huge amount to go through
this slight recess will last about 20
minutes as the jury was led out coroner
thanked them very briefly but again one
member of the family stood up looked to
the back towards everyone and said thank
you to the jury and again the whole
court erupted in applause as one after
the other the jury members the longest
serving to relay race illegally Airi
themselves laid out I mean what
to be going through their minds at the
weight of expectation